ryan is captured on set throwing a punch
at his co-star mark ruffalo
as he films his latest netflix movie the
atom project yesterday in vancouver
ryan is also spotted filming in front of
a blue screen alongside an armored
soldier
the sci-fi movie which doesn't have a
release date yet is about a man who
travels back in time to get help from
his younger self to confront his late
father
how long have you known each other
though you both since i was 17 years old
wait 17. and i was five and i was five
days
it's an american idol reunion as former
judges paula abdul and randy jackson
stopped by to visit original idol winner
kelly clarkson on her talk show how did
you meet
well i used to teach dance and
cheerleading camps and
um where we were teaching a lot i
thought of
an idea to give the winners who would
win in competitions
the concerts that were in town and it
just so happened to be a journey
and i got all these cheerleaders who won
you know prizes and awards
to come to the show and i took them
backstage and we were all in our
in our cheer gear and we met randy
as the bass player oh that's so crazy
and victoria and david beckham's 18 year
old son romeo is all grown up
as he makes his magazine debut posing
for the first of four covers
of lomo vogue's generation issue out
january 22nd
inside the magazine he's also snapped
eating an ice cream cone and in another
photo
he's seen showing off his abs some can't
help but notice a strong resemblance to
his dad
who also shared the magazine images on
his instagram
saying how proud he is and it's just
been announced that country singer garth
brooks will be performing
at u.s president-elect joe biden's
inauguration tomorrow
this is a great day in our household
this is not a political statement this
is a statement of unity
garth who has performed for numerous
presidents in the past
joins lady gaga and jennifer lopez who
are also slated to perform at the
inauguration ceremonies